the stable match problem that we just
looked at is one example of a bipartite
matching problem so the setup with a
bipartite matching problem is you've got
a a simple graph and the vertices are
split into two groups as in the stable
matching problem we can call them the
girls and the boys the G and the B and
so the definition of a bartók bipartite
graph is a graph where there are some
vertices called the left vertices and a
disjoint set of vertices called the
right vertices in every vertex is either
left or right and edges only go between
a left vertex and a right vertex now in
this case the matching problem what we
want to consider is that there's a
specification that each girl is willing
to be paired with certain boys and but
not all of them so we can specify that
by adding edges where if this is the
first girl in the list then she is
willing to be paired with the second boy
and the last boy and that's what those
two edges indicate so edges are
signaling compatibility constraints on
matching up the girls and the boys and
what we're trying to accomplish is
getting all of the girls matched with a
unique boy match each girl to a unique
compatible boy so there's an example of
a match where there's one highlighted
magenta edge out of each girl and they
go to different boys so we formally we
want a by jek ssin from the girls to the
boys that is that follows edges well
let's look at a case where I I can't
find a match suppose that that edge was
missing we use that meju in the match
but let's suppose it was not there let's
get rid of it and what we find now is
that this last girl no longer can be
matched to be a to this second boy which
is what we previously had so let's try
to find some other match and there isn't
any and the reason is that if you look
at this group of three girls on the left
and you look at all of the boys on the
right that they are collectively
compatible with that is one of these
three girls at least
is willing to be paired with one of the
boys on the right there are only two
boys that have to be shared among three
girls and that is what's example of
what's called a bottleneck so if we have
three girls and collectively they only
like two boys they're just are not
enough boys to go around for these girls
that proves that a match is not going to
be possible so more generally if you
have a set s of girls on the left and
you look at the image of s under the
edge relation that is e of S which is
collectively the set of all of the boys
that are compatible with one or more of
the girls in s then whenever you have so
we previously just had an example where
s was three and E of s was two and
because three was greater than two
because s was greater than e of s we
were bottle necked and we couldn't
possibly find a match and more generally
the definition of a bottleneck is that
if you have a set where the size of s is
greater than the size of the image of s
then that's called a bottleneck and the
first observation we can make is the
bottleneck lemma says that um a
bottleneck is a set s of girls without
enough boys um and if s is greater than
e of s that's called a bottleneck and
when there is one no match is possible
obviously yeah so this is a reason why
there might not be a match is that
there's a bottleneck now a rather deep
theorem is conversely if there are no
bottlenecks then in fact there is a
match this is known as halls theorem
it's not obvious although we'll find an
understandable proof of it and that's
what we're going to do in the next
segment